I like hearing ravens around when I’m
hunting.
Let’s me know that the game is out there.
That’s how you pray to the raven.
Great, great grandma Alda taught me.
“Grandma, I have bad luck,
I can’t get moose.”
She told me, “Pray to the raven then.”
And so I prayed to the raven,
I got a moose after that.
I feel really good about my girls future.
Ten, fifteen years from now,
they're going to have their own families
and they're going to be
bringing their kids out and showing them
different lands, landmarks,
hills, and creeks.
Trying, I’m trying, I’m trying to get this bull to walk
towards us.
It's not an everyday opportunity
out here to shoot a moose.
It'll feed a lot of people.
Most of times
when I call out moose like this,
they'll come directly to the call.
So, I'm not sure if he seen us.
Maybe he spotted us up here
on this little hill. It was
He must keep his cow in that back
lake back there.
He’s just pushing us away maybe.
Don’t even want to fight.
Yeah, ‘cause he’s
coming in close but doesn’t want to fight.
Just like he’s protecting his cow.
You definitely need a lot of patience
to be successful in this country.
You think we should come back to this
lake?
Yeah.
Seems pretty promising.
Oh, yeah.